>> CHRIS: We're headed out
to Horse Island.
The Peabody has been
in possession of this island
since the early 1970s.
We're currently building
a teaching pavilion
in partnership
with the architecture school.
>> ALAN: He said well how about
if you guys could build a lab
building for us a new
building that would be
off the grid.
This is the first project
of the new
Regenerative Building Lab at
the Yale School
of Architecture
which is a sort
of advanced version of the Yale
building project.
>> KATIE: It was sort of a crazy
time to graduate.
So it worked out really
well to have this unique
but temporary project
to work on.
>> LOUIS: The seminar started as
the
Regenerative Building Seminar
as a spring course.
Last semester turned
into a design phase
and then ultimately now
into the construction
phase of the Yale Peabody
Coastal Research Center.
>> ALAN: The idea
of this building
is to provide a sort of hub
for researchers
who are visiting doing work
for classes coming to study
parts of the island.
>> NICOLE: But of course
it's also a bit
of a balancing act, right?
Because this is a preserve
in a way and we want
to preserve it because otherwise
the research that you can
do here is not going to be
that exciting if we have
damaged the ecosystem too much.
>> LOUIS: Design for disassembly
is the idea of using
screws and fasteners
which you could remove.
So theoretically you could take
this building apart the same
way that you put it together.
>> KATIE: And because we
prefabricated so much
of the building on West Campus,
how we were gonna make those
components and then disassemble
them and package them to be
able to rebuild them
really efficiently here
where we're lacking a lot
of our tools and equipment.
>> ALAN: So when the building
is ultimately
disassembled we can reuse
all of the materials again.
>> KATIE: I'm pretty confident
that we'll have it ready
for use in late spring.
>> LOUIS: Every day is a fun new
problem to solve and a lot
of variety a lot
of different things.
It certainly beats the monotony
of sitting at a computer all day
long so it's it's really fun.
>> ALAN: As one of the guys
on the crew says
this is the best day of my life.
And he says it every day.
So I think that's a good sign.